[Music]
in
Christian
[Music]
for
welcome so excited you're here um my
name is Rachel I've got some
announcements for you today um the first
one is it's the first of the month so
right after service we have uh hat Creek
off of Highway 78 um and Woodbridge
Parkway in saxi so right after our
service we're all going to head over
there um it's a great way to connect
with people um and make some friends all
those things um next is if you're
interested in making the table your
church home or um just learning more
about the uh the table uh we have a
class for that uh welcome to the table
is on Sunday April 28th from 3: to 4:30
p.m. and there is a QR code you can scan
for that um and then next Megan is going
to come up and talk about
meetups so I'm really excited to
announce that we're going to be starting
a new style of meetups we've got some
that meet at homes that are you know
share life sort of groups we've got some
that are more like Affinity based you
know like the men's discipleship group
or 20s something's brunch we're starting
something called Sprint groups and these
are intended to be short groups that run
maybe for a month maybe up to three
months and uh they can be whatever you
want not really they're tied to our core
values and they have some intention of
of bringing people together so I'm
announcing our first Sprint meetup group
is going to be starting in two weeks
April 21st it's going to be here Sunday
at the church at 3:00 so if you're
already coming to the church for service
anyway you can come a little bit early
it's called not your mama's Sunday
school class so this is the Sunday
school class where you're like I really
want to dive into scripture but I want
to be able to have ask questions that
maybe in other settings might be a
little heretical or a little I'd be too
embarrassed to ask this cuz I don't want
to look dumb no this is the place to
come to ask those sorts of questions so
two weeks from now 3:00 not your mama
Sunday school second if you've got a
Meetup Group idea of something like that
Sprint it could be something like um a
summer foodie Club maybe every Friday in
the summer you want to go and just eat
good food in Dallas or maybe you like
board games and want to start a board
gum board game group great come have a
conversation with me we can talk about
Sprint
meetups
all right um I'm going to go ahead and
lead us in prayer so if you'll bow your
heads with me Jesus uh we thank you so
much for this place um for a place where
everyone is welcome we thank you for
your goodness um and for your love and
we just ask that you be with us uh
throughout this service in your name we
pray
amen thank you Rachel she did an awesome
job it's her first time on announcements
thank you so
much and speaking of first times um can
you guys also welcome Nate he has jumped
in very quickly on drums and we are so
excited to have him with us playing
along so you guys stand up we're going
to get started with Psalm 116 tonight um
so y'all sing
along I love you
Lord for you have delivered
me I love love you
Lord for you have delivered my soul from
Death my feet from stumbling I will walk
in the land of the living my soul from
in the land of the
[Laughter]
living
[Music]
let's sing that again I love you
Lord I love you
Lord for you have delivered
me I love you
Lord for you have delivered my soul from
Death my feet from stumbling I will walk
in the land of the living my soul from
in the land of the
[Music]
living
sing I Will Bless I Will Bless You Lord
For You Heard My Cry I reached out my
head and you saved my life I will bless
you Lord for you heard my plea and the
guide of Heaven turn his ear to me I
will bless you Lord for unending love
for your grace and mercy raining down
from above I Will Bless You Lord to the
very end I will call on you as long as I
may live I love you
Lord for you have delivered
me oh I love you
Lord for you have delivered my soul from
Death my feet from stumbling I will walk
in the land of the living my soul from
in the land of the
living all right you kiddos are
dismissed to go to your classrooms your
teachers will meet you over by the door
so please wait for them please wait for
them hint hint wink
wink I just got to say how much I loved
that snare just
then what a gift okay um we're going to
go ahead and transition into the prayers
of the people so um I think most of you
have been with us before but if you
haven't we just want to lift up what
we're carrying into this space together
we want to lift it up before God and uh
we want to shoulder each other's burdens
so let's read through the prayer
together and then we'll have some space
where you can speak out a name or a
situation that's on your heart and then
we'll close out the prayer together at
the
end would you guys read along with me
for this city of saxi Texas and for
every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you for the good
Earth you have given us and the wisdom
and the will to conserve it we pray to
you for the old and the sick for the
Widow and orphan for the injured and
suffering we pray to
you for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them we pray to you for the
vulnerable the marginalized and those
unjustly targeted for their gender
sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you for those
experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to you Lord we know that you love us and
that you hear us so we lift these names
and situations up to
you
[Music]
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts
we pray to you that they may have life
and light healing and hope peace and a
deep sense of your presence
[Music]
amen
I search the
world he couldn't F
me started on the wrong time signature
here let's let's start over sorry guys
let's try that again all
[Music]
right
I search the
world he couldn't fill
me and manty praise and Treasures of
faith and never
enough and you came
along and put me back together
together and every desire is now
satisfied here in your
love oh there's
nothing better than you Lord there's
nothing nothing is better than
you I know it's
true I'm not
afraid to show you my
weakness failures and flaws but you see
them all and you still call me
friend cu the god of the
mountains he's the god of the
valley is not a place your mercy and
Grace won't find me
[Music]
again oh there's
nothing better than you there's
nothing better than you Lord there
nothing nothing is better than
you oh there's
nothing better than you Lord there's
nothing better than you Lord's
nothing nothing is better than
you I know it's true
[Music]
you turn morning to
dancing you get Beauty for
[Music]
ases you turn shame into
Glory you're the only one who
car you turn
into
Gard you turn bones into
our you turn Seas into
highways you're the only one who
came you turn morning to
daning you give youy
fores you turn shame into Glory
you're the only one who
car you turn graes into
Gardens you turn bones into
armies you turn Seas into
highways you're the only one
who you're the only one who
can you're the only one
[Music]
who I want to read a passage tonight out
of Isaiah
55 so if you'll just close your eyes
with
me try to put your mind in a posture of
just listening to the spirit of
God his still small
voice
he says
come all you who are
thirsty come to the waters and you who
have no money come buy and
eat come buy wine and milk without money
without
cost why spend money on on what is not
bread and your labor on what does not
satisfy listen
listen listen to me eat what is good and
you will Delight in The Riches of
fair give ear and come to me listen that
you may
live I will make an Everlasting Covenant
with you my faithful
love seek the Lord while he may be found
call on him while he is is near let the
wicked forsake their ways and the
unrighteous their thoughts let them turn
to the Lord and He will have mercy on
them and to our God for he will freely
pardon for my thoughts are not your
thoughts neither are your ways my ways
declares the
Lord as the heavens are higher than the
earth so are my my ways higher than your
ways and my thoughts than your
[Music]
thoughts
come to the white
a all who are
[Music]
thirsty come and
dream come to the
table all who are
hungry come
and
[Music]
feast those who are
we those who are
needy come
[Music]
receive come to the
r come to the
riv
tast and
[Music]
see sing that again come come to the
water all who are thirst
come and
dream come to the
table all who are
hungry come then
[Music]
Feast those who are
wey those who are need
[Music]
come
receive Come to the
[Music]
River Come to the
River taste and
[Music]
see oh my
soul for
you and you
alone oh my
soul thir for
you and you
are
o oh my
soul there for
you and you
are oh my
soul it thirst for
you you
[Music]
are we love more
you
you I will
taste and see that you are
good I will
good you're good to me he is Good's sing
it out I will I will
taste and see that you are
good I will
taste see that you are
taste and see that you are
good you're good to me
oh oh my
soul it thirst for
you and you
[Music]
are oh my
soul thirst for you
and you
[Music]
are oh my
soul it there for
you and you
[Music]
are oh my soul
it you
[Music]
all your ways and all your
thoughts we want you
guys
so
our so much deeper is your
sing come come to
the all who are
thirsty come and
drink come to the
table come to the
table all who are
[Music]
hungry
come and
[Music]
PE God the only way that I can sing
those words is because you have shown
yourself to be a good and kind and
loving
God the only way I can desire more of
you is because you have shown yourself
to be steadfast in the middle of the
storm you have been an anchor you have
been our
Rock You have been our
home God at times when it didn't feel
like we could find love anywhere else we
have found it in your
arms when it has felt that we are at the
end of our rope and we are surrounded by
Darkness I have found your light to
stay and to hold
us and to ground
[Music]
us God would we experience more of that
in our lives would we share more of that
with this world a hope that doesn't
stop
life and love that isn't
conditional that has no
[Music]
end would we come to know you as a good
God as our
[Music]
source thank you for who you are we want
to know you
more it's in your name I pray all these
things
[Music]
amen will you guys turn to the people
around you and welcome them and then
Brett will come and get us started on
our
[Music]
message
and uh yeah I'm really excited for this
this whole um the whole season we're
getting into but before I get into all
that I want to not only welcome you all
but include those join us online love
yall Lots um and one here who's kind of
feeling new to the community um we're
glad that you're here as well so um we
are into a uh kind of a new series it's
going to be titled practicing
Resurrection um I don't know about you
growing up for me like Easter at least
the church Traditions I participated in
Easter was like a day and uh for most of
like the broader i' say like Global
church at least um is mostly an entire
season which makes sense if you have
like the season of lint you know which
is kind of preparation heart preparation
for like the cross it you know it would
be a little out of balance to do like 40
days you know repentance and and uh kind
of meditating on the cross and and such
and then uh you know one day of like
hooray he's risen all right well that's
it you know and kind of move on um so
that's where here at the table we want
to kind of join in with the the broader
Church in what's known as Easter tide
and uh yeah kind of participate in
practice um Resurrection so we we're
doing this the series is kind of the
idea is um right so Christ is risen what
does that mean for us uh what what kind
of rhythms what kind of practices what
kind of people are we called to be in
light of the resurrection of Jesus and
uh so we're going to follow What's
called the lectionary which is like the
prescribed kind of readings and each
time uh and I follow the United
methodists kind of their Church calendar
and so there's always a reading from the
book of Acts at least in this year of
the lectionary so I'm just going to kind
of stick to like the book of Acts it'll
be like very kind of early church
looking at some of the the ways and
rhythms and things that um that they did
in light of the resurrection and you
know of course kind of gleaning what we
can for our own lives and Church
community and and such so uh the passage
today it's a fun one it's a famous one
and uh at least it'll be it'll be
recognizable to many of you so the title
of the message is no needy among
them and then we've got acts chap 4 vers
verses
32-35 which says all the Believers were
one in heart and mind no one claimed
that any of their possessions was their
own but they shared everything they had
with great power the apostles continued
to testify to the resurrection of the
Lord Jesus and God's grace was so
powerfully at work in them all that
there were no needy persons among them
for from time to time those who own land
or houses sold them brought the money
from the sales and put it at the
apostles feet and it was distributed to
anyone who had
need so I'm kind of curious like how
this hits you I kind of open with that
sometimes when it's like a interesting
passage you know where people have
feelings or thoughts or interpretations
or such um you know I'm kind of I don't
know maybe for some of you it's like a
maybe like a
lifegiving description of like what the
church could be you know and oh it's
just like that sounds amazing maybe
others of you are kind of like feeling a
little hesitant like I don't I don't
know about that where where's this going
you know um it's maybe it could also be
read as like very I'd say politically
sort of
subversive uh I mean this would be like
a favorite passage of KL Marx for
example you know um it's like that's
what I'm talking about you know uh and
uh and maybe I was speak even for myself
like when I came across this in election
are I groaned a little bit I think
because I feel a little bit guilty like
something that's strange about pastoring
or maybe I don't know a experience
unique to pastoring is like you're sort
of well you can go into the idea of
pastoring in church and especially
church planting where it's a little more
of a blank slate not totally but a
little more than you know when you're
coming into a church with like all the
ideals you know of like oh my goodness
we could just you know but you are very
quickly hit with
like like
realities like re you know so I read
this and I on the one hand I'm kind of
like honestly like yes that sounds
amazing but then like my practical I've
done this for I mean not like 30 years
pastoring but I've done this for long
enough to know like like if we actually
try to just literally like so we're
doing it we're implementing this you
know what I mean like it could I could
see the challenges let's put it that way
like you know like we could see the like
oh this it's so my feel I don't know I
feel all sorts of feelings around it
like there's something in me that's like
it's beautiful another part of me is
like I don't
know there was uh I should say my so
kind of my hope as we go through this
and the way we'll we'll follow we're
just going to literally like kind of
walk through the passage and uh just
unpack kind of each each sentence or two
and uh as we do this my hope is like
something without I don't trying not to
fall into like a kind of guilt tripping
uh kind of moralistic sermon you know
like that's where I could kind of sense
this could go is sort of like why aren't
we doing better you know or something
along those lines so I really hope I
want to challenge as we get towards the
end of the message you'll see that there
is some challenge here but um but
hopefully without I don't know a kind of
heavy-handed um yeah heavy-handedness
there's a a quote I love from it's Mark
Vernon he's actually drawing this from a
writer named Owen Barfield um and he put
it this way he said the truth must be
felt as much as analyzed that's kind I
want you to take that into this message
like what's the feel is there some
feeling is there some kind of Whisper of
the spirit is there some call for you
you know that might be different than
the person sitting next to you or or
whatever you know so okay so let's walk
through this uh verse 32 all the
Believers were one in heart in heart and
mind which is how this begins it's
interesting this was the line that kind
of jumped out at me like you know you
read a passage a lot and uh sometimes
you read it again for the first time so
to speak like something AC is grabbing
um you know you it's like something
jumps out and it was this I had honestly
never noticed this line all the
Believers were one in heart and mind it
seems to me that's like a really kind of
um it's like the key to the whole thing
because notice how it doesn't open it it
doesn't begin and all of the Believers
felt incredibly guilty over everything
that they owned or all the Believers
live lived in constant fear of letting
God
down so because of that they claimed no
possessions as their own or the bishop
or the pastor declared that hey got a
new some new rules we're implementing so
no one was able to claim any possessions
as their own that's not how it it's
actually begins right with this kind of
heart mind thing that
actually right in other words it wasn't
kind of an external imposed kind of
force actually this is where chapter 5
which follows I find a bit problematic
it's the story of ananas and saf which
if you're familiar with it I would say
it's one of the more terrible stories in
the New Testament um it's I mean there
is something I could preach on it there
is Beauty and or there's Beauty that's
not the right word there's truth or
there's something there for us I'd have
to totally um read it metaphorically um
taken as a just so story basically an
ananas and Safara they um sell some
property and such but they only bring
like part of the money and lie about it
and say oh it's all of it you know but
it's not and then like the text doesn't
say and then God smited them doesn't say
that it is implied you know they just
they die you know and and that's the the
kind of I'd say trouble there is you can
see the kind of
reintroduction of of kind of a uh a sort
of heavy handed you know a kind of fear
thing like hey maybe everyone's not
going to get on board with this so let's
tell this story you know what I mean
like ah I I prefer this opening I like
this opening that in other words it's
not the Lord's going to get you if you
don't you know but it's it's no no no
all the Believers they were one in heart
in
mind uh there's something have you ever
felt the sense of Oneness with people
that's amazing isn't it like you're just
doesn't even necess mean we agree on
everything you know like everyone's of
course still different and but there's
like a when you're just synced up when
there's a value connection when when
there's just I don't know you just
there's trust you know and it's like I'm
for them they're for me I know this and
that's um in fact the the word for um
charity is the the root of it from the
it comes from the Latin um kitas which
it means love right so it's not the more
secular idea of Charity which is
something like um pity mingled with
financial assistance you know um true
kind of charity it's you could it's the
same word as love in other words there
was a a loving
Oneness among them and from that kind of
loving Oneness a charitableness
just began to
happen like can you see where it's a
it's a side effect the the giving the
generosity is a it's a side effect of of
this of them being one in heart heart
and mind we might sum it up by saying
nothing enlivens generosity more than a
sense of
Oneness I mean just think of like the
people you're the most quick to give to
and I don't even just mean financially
just time energy love you know just
attention um it's often it's those you
feel the most one with where there's
that one you know and for some of us
it's um
I mean it may even just be ourselves you
know we don't think anything of like
taking care of ourselves feeding
ourselves giving you we don't think like
oh how charitable I am I'm feeding
myself today it's like what no it's like
I I love myself I want to take care of
myself of course you know and then same
maybe just keep that Circle of Care that
that Oneness maybe it expands out to
like immediate family you know and again
you don't think like oh how magnanimous
of I fed my children everyone everyone
Facebook post I fed my my kids today you
know it's just like of course of I hope
so like there's just you don't even
think of it as doing a good thing you
know and maybe you're um friends You'
give them you know as the saying goes
the shirt off your back you know your
last nickel or whatever I think that's
something my grandpa was like give him
give him my last nickel you know and
without thinking about it why it's
Oneness now the challenge comes of
course as we keep expanding that for
some of us it doesn't expand very far
you know it is sort of like well my
family I care for my family everyone
else best of luck you know or my friends
perhaps my church or at least the people
I know at church you know or whatever
like there's kind of this and and I
wonder in fact I I wonder if a uh a good
kind of way to judge our own kind of
spiritual maturity is asking ourselves
like how far does that sense of Oneness
like kind of
expand you know where where is that for
you you might ask just how much Oneness
do I feel with others it's a key
question how much Oneness do I feel with
others verse 32 continues so no one
claimed any of their possessions was
their own but they
shared everything they
had just let that those lines sink in no
one claimed
any of their possessions as their own
they shared everything they
had I saw a few eyebrows go up kind of
like yeah because it's amazing how we
can kind of read the Bible you know just
s of like oh yeah that's sweet sweet we
just kind of read it and move on but
it's like wait wait wait what did that
just
say like just imagine what what would
that be like what would it be like to
live in this kind of with this kind of
heart no one claiming possessions as
their own I would say this is a tough
one this is a tough one for humans in
general
uh I think for Americans in particular
it's
like I don't know about this at all you
know it's just there's something in it
because we we definitely have a strong
kind of individualistic Street that's a
value of ours you know individualism and
uh and along with that there's certain
rights and you know the right to
property the right to our stuff you know
like gosh darn it it's mine then don't
tell me otherwise you know and there's
there's something in us that kind of is
like he this this is difficult teaching
you
know difficult few um years ago I wanted
to uh try to work on this I'm a INR
five so I'm like pretty lost in my mind
and uh at my worst I can be like very
sort of self focused self-absorbed just
sort of in my world and unaware
unattuned to others and how they're
doing and you know um um and so I wanted
to you know try to be better at this so
I made this decision there's a actually
a passage it's from Matthew 5 46-47
where he kind of there's an echo here of
Christ where he said these words um if
you love those who love you what reward
will you get are not even the tax
collectors doing that if you greet only
your own people what are you doing more
than others do not uh even the pagans do
that and uh there's another pastor talks
about just lending to those who asked to
borrow from you you know and so I kind
of this is probably I don't know 8 10
years ago and I told myself like okay
I'm just going to do this like if anyone
asks to borrow something from me I'm
just like the answer is
yes and uh it was quite the grand little
experiment um I think I get like kind of
to Jesus passage with my friends
honestly I mean it was like a little
sacrifice but like truth be told not
that much you know because I mean a I'm
an American so I like have lots of
things half of it just sitting around
you know it's like there's stuff in my
garage like hey can I borrow that and it
just wasn't a too big a deal you know to
be like sure I guess the only maybe
adjustment was in the past I probably
would have said yes but I would like
yeah um and I would be like thinking you
know what I mean like yeah yeah um Let
me let me think on that whereas so this
so the practice was to sort of just be
like yes let me figure out how that can
happen you know that was kind of the
invitation but like I named with my
friends it just wasn't like that big of
sacrifice uh most they would borrow a
thing and then it would be like back in
my garage like two days later you no
bigs like I had a friend for example um
I'll mention his organization later
10,000 homes Jeremy price and he was
he's a a missionary in South Africa
would come back to the States
periodically and so like I had this car
that would just sit there because I
either worked from home or the church I
worked at at that time was so close I
rode my bike so the car just sat in my
driveway so that's a good example he
would reach out ask hey can I borrow
that car sure yes you know but again was
this a big SA was this like oh wow you
know According To Jesus I mean if you if
you lend to those who would lend right
back to you like what is is this really
that you know and uh so then one day a
uh a gentleman he showed up at the
church and uh he
was a few months he said months probably
meant weeks um off of drugs you know had
it just lived a hard life he was um
living outside in Wy you'd be surprised
how many people are living outside in
even the suburbs like they're just there
in those those woods you know in the
kind of green belt where they can't
build someone's got a tent out there you
know they're on Lake leavon they have to
patrol the lake and like see a tent
that's like randomly not in a campsite
and then you know so that's where he was
he was at the at Lake leavon uh living
out there and uh so he he came one day
telling me a story and uh
I kind of knew where things were going
and I knew my little commit my
commitment you know and I was like oh no
and he's like man you know what I could
really use a bike and a
tint he's like a bike to get to work
because I'm walking right now and it was
like eight miles you know in a tent
because the mosquitoes are eating me
alive it was August September kind of
time and he's like do you have a bike in
a ENT I was like I do I do have a bike
and a tint I have both of those things
awesome and so I just said you know what
heck yeah man they are yours and
uh he used them he's still using
them uh he actually it went quite well
for like a few weeks he would like text
me like hey man thanks and we got coffee
a few times and then of course you know
um he he vanished Into The Ether I was
thinking actually this week as I was
working on this message I was like you
know maybe he's still borrowing them you
know maybe he really needed them like
you still you know a guy can dream you
um and going through
that I think I learned a lot like I
think I learned mostly it wasn't so much
about him or like be careful people rip
you all I mean of course we know this
like um I knew it going in I knew this
is this isn't going to end well you know
he's going to pawn these things um but I
think what it showed me I probably would
have told you before then I'm not
attached to my thing
they're just things you know it's people
that matter that's what I tell my kids
it's people that matter things don't
matter but just watch someone take a few
of my
things and just watch me get all up in
you know just wow at least internally I
didn't outwardly I played it cool but um
internally I was
struggling no one claimed any of their
possessions were their own they they
shared everything they had and uh and
sometimes they even got ripped
off and sometimes it went sideways and
doesn't work out by the way I'm not
saying there's never a place for
boundaries bless you the Lord bless you
um there's never a place for boundaries
or you know that's a whole other
conversation but but might there be some
invitation to us to like I don't know
not always be so wise a serpents you
know there's some place to be innocent
as a dove once in a while give people a
chance generosity flows when I think of
my money and my possessions on loan to
me rather than
mine M I think that's what's that's at
least something I'm drawn from this
passage even if I I don't quite know how
to apply it like literally to the table
and we'll just start doing that you know
I don't know how to do all that um at
the very least I think we could start
kind of loosening this death grip we
have on our stuff you know and and like
learn to be live more lightly and freely
and
generously H that's it's almost like
we'll never do it out there in the world
until we can kind of do it you know
until there's a shift in our own heart
and mind and even here in the the
context of of our own Community verse
33 with great power the apostles
continued to testify to direction of the
Lord Jesus and God's grace was so
powerfully at work in them all that
there were no needy persons among
them that's the kind of beautiful payoff
of living like this no needy persons
among them I I wonder um what would it
be like to expand our
them in this passage it seems to be
pretty zered in on like that you know
the Christian Community and maybe to
some degree those they were in contact
with but I wonder like what if because
honestly if to them is just like
literally us I think with a few gifts to
our benevolence fund we can like pretty
much you know like be there for each
other help each other through job loss
and you know um I mean honestly very few
probably no one at the table is going to
starve to death this year you know very
unlikely uh but you start that them
starts expanding out across the city
across the country across the world and
I'm thinking now of like the global kind
of body of Christ I think is even more
than just like church people you know
it's like a I think it's broader than
that no need what it be like a world no
needy persons among
them the uh there's a wonderful book I
honestly I haven't read it if you think
every time I quote a book that means
I've read the whole book you'd be wrong
my friend um I'm not reading two books a
week you know um but this I love this
title I've never forgotten this title
like I just heard the title and then the
title came to me as I was writing this
message so this is the title it's
hard-hitting it won't lie Rich
Christians in an age of hunger
oh doesn't that just doesn't that just
kind of hit you rich Christians and by
the way he's not talking about you know
those darn
multi-millionaires you know it's really
the West it's it's Western Christians in
a world still of global hunger and you
know and so I have just a few quotes I
want to close with with these these will
these will get you thinking my at least
that's my hope we need to make some
dramatic concrete moves uh Ronald cider
by the way wrote this uh concrete moves
to escape the materialism that seeps
into our minds via diabolically clever
and incessant
advertising we've been brainwashed to
believe that bigger houses more
prosperous businesses and more
sophisticated gadgets are the way to Joy
and fulfillment as a result we are
caught in an absurd materialistic spiral
and then he describes it the more we
make see if you can relate to this the
more we make the more we think we need
in order to live decently and respect
ly somehow we've got to break the cycle
because it makes us sin against our
needy brothers and sisters and therefore
against our Lord and it also destroys us
sharing with others is the way to real
joy every bit is hard-hitting as the
title of his book huh here's one more
quote from him this is shorter dare we
care at all about current Fashions if
that means reducing our ability to help
hungry
neighbors how many more luxuries should
we buy for ourselves and our children
children when others are dying for lack
of
bread
o it's a good
question remember at the beginning of
the message when I said I want you to
feel the truth of a thing my point isn't
to be sort of heavy-handed and
moralistic and make everyone feel guilty
and you know ra what I'd rather do is I
hope you feel kind of like the
invitation from the Holy Spirit to like
a different way of living that is just
as generous as possible I'm not saying
like you can never buy a nice thing you
know or you have two cars how dare you
you know um but there's what's the
invitation for you um in
this if you need a place to begin I want
to offer you a few suggestions here's a
few wonderful organizations you can do a
Google search on these uh so Five Loaves
food pantry if you need a place to give
this would be great this is a local food
pantry and saxi and they're doing good
work and we support them as a church but
I'd love if like some of us could you
know start start giving maybe it's like
that when I'm thinking of luxur ciders
luxuries I'm thinking of like how big is
that Starbucks budget you know what I
mean like those are the again not saying
it can't never go to Starbucks but I
don't know where is that how what how
much molas go into that and might it be
cut so that someone else could have
their bread you know so Five Loaves
Compassion International another great
organization 10,000 homes uh that's the
one my friend works for um and they're
building um uh homes for uh AIDS orphans
there in South Africa uh and then
finally the table benevolence fund so if
you were to give to the table and Market
specifically for that fund then it goes
to folks who maybe hit a hard time um
you know job loss things like that and
then we can we can give so um anyway
those are just practical ways you know
that we can start um pressing into this
and uh yeah my hope is we can kind of
receive that that invitation from the
spirit to uh to not
be um who Christ would not have us
be so in the name of the Father the Son
and the Holy Spirit
amen so as we uh as we come to the table
of the
Lord as we take in the body of Christ
and the bread the blood of Christ and
the wine if you think about it it's a
moment where we are receiving the
generous
goodness of God and we take in the bread
we take in Christ himself and then we go
out those doors and what do we
do we give we give in a lot of ways we
give so that's my kind of my prayer as
you come forward that that you be able
to receive uh so that you can you can
give so the way we'll um kind of do this
tonight we'll just go row by row here um
we practice an open table so everyone
here is welcome to come forward if you
would like the red is wine the white as
grape
juice and finally you can just partake
whenever and however you'd like so um
this is the table not of the church but
of the Lord and it's made ready for
those who love him and for those who
want to love him more so come you who
have much faith and you who have little
you who have been here often and you who
have not been here long you who have
tried to follow and you who have
failed come because it's the Lord Jesus
himself who invites you and it's his
will that those who want to meet him
should meet him here come to the
[Music]
table
we're going to close with a hymn called
take my life and um just in that Spirit
of generosity um recognizing that what
what we've been given by God we want to
give back to him we want to allow him
full ownership and um use of who we are
and and who we've become and what we
have so would you guys stand with us as
we sing this last
song guys can follow
[Music]
Maggie take my
life and let it
be
cons Lord to
be take my
moments and my
days let them flow in
ceaseless
praise let them flow in
praise take my hands
take my hands and let them
move at the
impulse of thy
love take my feet and let them
be Swift and
beautiful for thee
Swift and
beautiful for
thee take my silver take my
silver and my
go not of Might would I
will take my in
[Music]
and
use
every
Power thy shal
choose every Power as Thou shalt
[Music]
choose take my love my Lord Lord I
pour at thy feet it
treasure
store take
myself and I will
be
ever
only all for
thee
ever only
all for
[Music]
the thank you so much for uh joining us
this evening if it's your first time
we'd love for you to fill out a card at
the table um or uh on the QR code and
that will allow us to follow up with you
um to answer any questions you might
have and just say thank you for being
here um if you are in need of prayer a
hug or just someone to talk to I will be
here after the service again my name's
Rachel hi um and I would love to be
there for you however I can um here at
the table we are committed to creating
an inclusive Christ centered community
that touches lives and generosity is a
key component of that mission I know for
my husband Gage and I we have been
looking for a place like the table for a
long time um that included everybody
especially the lgbtq plus Community um
and and so it has been an honor and um
so healing for us to be able to be a
part of the work that is done here um so
I would encourage you to pray about that
and think about that as well um if you'd
like to join us in supporting the work
that the table does financially you can
scan that QR code as well on the screens
um or you can go to the website the tabl
tx.org um don't forget you can take next
steps on Sprint meetups as well as
welcome to the table um by scanning that
QR code um and we'd love to have you
join us at hat Creek Burger uh right
after this um so please join us we'd
love to have you there um now I'm going
to send you into a week with a blessing
um you can hold your hands out in a
posture of receiving or um you could
just open your heart to hear these
words you are a child of
God you are a child of God this is true
on your best day and this is true on
your worst day so as you go into week
your head you go into your week ahead
with its yet to be determined highs and
lows and everything in between go filled
with the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy and you are accepted just
as you are and go filled with God's Holy
Spirit and the desire to extend these
same Gifts of Grace and unconditional
love to everyone you come into contact
with be blessed have a beautiful week
don't forget about hat Creek and we hope
to see you back here next Sunday at 400
p.m. question mark that's what it
says okay 500 P PM just kidding see you
at 5:00 P PM next week good
night